I think we have to realize that time
does not give a [__] about the human
race right time doesn't care if we got
hit by an asteroid and this whole planet
got knocked back down into the Jurassic
period again right that totally could
happen it's happened before it's the
reason why we're here in the first place
supposedly right the the Yucatan impact
if that happens again time doesn't care
do
can we can we do anything to the
asteroid now that we're more advanced
they are slowly but surely being able to
recognize where they the real problem
supposedly I believe is ones that come
from too near the sun right the problem
is the gravity of the sun I'm sure I'm
[__] this up I'm sorry uh I think the
gravity of the Sun the mass of the Sun
is so immense that it's difficult to see
objects that are behind it coming
towards us so something's passing the
Sun and going towards us we might not
see it until it's too late to do
anything about it and then even if we do
see it there's only a few different
methods that they've devised that seem
to like one of them is you like hit it
with a surface like something lands on
it and this changing of the aerodynamics
of it like changes its trajectory in
some way and another one is breaking it
up the breaking it up one scares people
though because they're like well if you
break it up into many pieces that you
just go to a bunch of different spots on
Earth and it has the same impact just
not one spot right like you might you
might actually maybe it would have
landed in the ocean and most people
would survive you might know more than I
do but we haven't had a really like
destructive asteroid impact in a in a
long time it's a timeline thing dude
right our timeline is our lifetime and
it's so long for a person and it's so
nothing for space right it's so nothing
it literally is nothing right our
timeline is 100 years for a human
timeline the the Earth is 4 whatever
billion years old the universe there's
all these arguments now the universe is
even older than 13.7 billion years ago
I'm not really smart enough to
understand it's something about the
forming of the galaxies like they seem
to form quicker that that wouldn't be
possible if the Earth was only or the
universe was only 13.7 billion years but
Brian keing doesn't agree with it so
maybe he's right I don't know who's
right what he said this guy said they
are properties of galaxies they're
rotating they're they're they're too
they're appearing too early on the
universe's early history um to have
developed into the spiral
characteristics and the population
distribution of them is too numerous to
have occurred in a universe that's only
quote unquote 13 billion years and you
actually said that you said like I
always thought you know 13 billion is a
pretty big number you know now they're
saying 27 so what's the difference but
there's a big difference because
implicit in that criticism is that there
are flaws and and imper infections and
how we understand the Big Bang either
way we're 100 Years of nothing it's so
quick and if we get hit with an asteroid
and then everything starts and it's
another 65 million years from now until
a new form of intelligent life arises
that the universe doesn't care about
that no right me me saying we haven't
had a significant impact is like when
your 13-year-old starts talking about
Israel and Palestine like they just
don't this is It's a it's I sound
ridiculous because it's literally I've
been on the planet 38 years and I'm like
we haven't had anything how you get
older you get old enough to realize this
hustle you get oh this this is a hustle
like you're you're pretending like you
can do something right you're pretending
like you're going to make a life and
leave a mark and all you're just moving
right and you're going to be gone and
new people are going to move into that
and everyone's affecting everybody and
we're all working towards some weird
goal right and some of it involves
rockets and computers and we're just
building Wilder and Wilder technology
but I don't know if we can escape before
something hits and I have a feeling
that's what's happened many times in the
past I think that's the biggest key to
the mystery of people and you think that
we may have gotten to this point I think
we definitely did where people were
podcasting in ridiculous coats yes and
then something comes and ruins it and
then it takes billions of years to get
back to that millions millions to get
back to that not really Millions I think
probably whatever the Egyptians were
doing I think they were the most
advanced civilization that ever existed
that's what I think this is to I mean
I'm out of line here for sure listen if
you're an archaeologist you're pulling
your hair out I get it but I don't think
we can do what they did I think if we
just look at it for just the sheer
Dynamics the volume of stone that they
moved the Precision in which they built
it I really don't think we can do that
just the symmetry of the faces of the
statues is
unparalleled and they're immense these
are monstrously huge perfectly
symmetrical faces right their their
temples are insanely intricate with
20 20 ton gigantic stone blocks that
were taken from a Mountain 500 miles
away and no one has any idea how the
[__] they got him nobody has any clue no
guesses right there's some guesses about
oh maybe the river system was different
back then whatever how are you getting
that 50 ton chunk of granite out of a
[__] mountain and moving it down even
with modern equipment how are you
getting it over the mountain so it seems
like you don't even have roads what you
they were incredibly Advanced incredibly
Advanced with math with science with
technology certainly with geometry
they also had an understanding of the
cosmos they definitely had an
understanding of the constellations and
that's one of the reasons why the The
Fringe theory is that the Sphinx is way
older than what they have it currently
dated at was like 2,500 BC which is
still crazy old right right but what
they think is it's probably older than
that maybe even 10,000 or 30,000 years
old and that at these times in whenever
the calendar is aligned properly
whatever the year is it's like exactly
where a lion would be staring the
constellation Leo